by a vote of 6 to 1
Ryan you are evicted from the Big
Brother house all right Ryan you just
got out of the Big Brother house how you
feeling what's going through your head
feel good you know
I had a great time in there I'm bummed
that I got evicted early but for them
like the just everything that's happened
in the Big Brother house I I had a lot
of fun there's a new experience it
looked like you had a lot of fun yeah
I'm gonna have a lot of time to process
that you were on the block cuz it
happened kind of all at one time yeah ah
when did you know you were going home
tonight um I think I kind of knew last
night the night before I just had a
feeling that you know I was gonna get
backdoored and I was gonna be put on the
block and get evicted because I mean I
was the biggest threat in the house I
was the most athletic and apparently
that's a no-no in the Big Brother house
it puts an immediate target on your back
opposed do you know who kind of
orchestrated this back door um I am
guessing it had a been a Lolo or Natalie
you are right on both accounts they kind
of caught up with Tom and Cato and put
this whole plan in place I knew it I
knew it
mm-hmm if you could go back and do
something differently about your game
what would you have changed um the very
beginning when me and Jonathan formed
our like own little secret alliance I
don't think we would've went to the
girls and formed their lines I think
that was the mistake that we made yeah
that bromance started bromine ardor day
one what is the bromance look like
outside of the house oh well I don't
know I'm waiting to get my phone so I
can call them up and be like what's up
buddy how about okay you're gonna have
watch parties the rest of the season
by all means because you didn't really
watch the show before you came on in
the show no it was a show before I came
on but now that I was I'm on the show I
was on the show I'm gonna watch it all
the time okay and I am a fan now you can
say Ryan is a Big Brother fan just
because like it's so entertaining like
it was so entertaining in the house
and I can't wait to see you like when
I'm actually watching it in my living
room so it's gonna be fun and it's gonna
be kind of strange because you get to go
home and watch all these people that you
are just in the house continue to play
the game yo and live in that house yeah
and like when they say sometimes like I
know what you feel I was there I was
there yeah so it's gonna be for now the
votes it was pretty much a landslide
there was just one vote that wasn't for
you yes you know who that was Joey yes I
really asked you does he stand a chance
in there without you I was like no he
doesn't I don't think he does just
because from what Cato said the night
before we're we said straight up I was
like hey man to man like do we need to
start packing he's like probably so I
mean I respect that he was really honest
and um so it was either between me or
Joey and they picked me so next if he
doesn't win HOH he's in trouble
okay one of my questions was who do you
think the next like target is Joe Joey
yeah should the next big target be who
should they be going after um Natalie or
Lola I think those are the two people
that are really smart about this game
and they're very good at manipulating
people in line so you have to go for
them safe to say you would think those
two are kind of running the house right
now yes 100%
Lola and Natalie are running the house
and you had to call it tonight who wins
this game it's between Cato and Natalie
um yes it's between one of those two
why Cato um like he's an athlete too
don't let him fool you with his jokes
and stuff he's an athlete and he's smart
he knows how to play the game
and he's a poker player too he reads
faces he knows when people are biessing
so I think it's gonna be cato or natalie
okay now you get to go back into freedom
tonight what's the first thing you're
gonna do when we let you out of here um
call my wife I mean yeah she's at home
with our son and we have a baby on the
way so I really want to just check up on
her and just hear a voice that's all I
want to do is hear her voice and then
I'll be a happy camper yeah you've had
what about two weeks away yes
locked up in that house no communication
with the outside world what surprised
you most about this kind of a very
strange experience oh it's not what you
like see on TV it's more intense than
that it is nothing I've ever experienced
I would train for years for one race for
the Olympics thing go through that like
that was just so intense of everyone
like forming alliances lying
manipulating is just yelling at each
other getting in fights it's it it was
it was an experience I'll never forget
that's for sure
[Applause]
[Music]